before we delve into the incredible
experiences we were treated to in May
let's first award a trophy to something
a little larger even though we've had a
steady stream of excellent games
demanding our attention since January it
wasn't until May that both the diversity
and quality of releases made us squeal
with joy so the month of the year award
goes to May for giving us something
marvelous every single week so what
games demanded our love though didn't
quite reach the heights of this month
winner well things started with the
competitive delights of sports friends
try not to laugh with befuddle meant as
you wildly contort your body in super
paul riders or succumb to the watery
depth in bara berry ball if you want
something more cerebral there's the
beautiful transistor which houses one of
the finest soundtracks around
Wolfenstein the new order provides
another tonal shift as Nazis meet their
long coming death and watchdogs
introduces a softer more peaceful
version of Chicago which leads us to our
two finalists the runner-up Mario caught
80 it was painful to keep trooper
trooper and company from reaching the
checkered flag mario kart 8 is saw a
blindingly fun that will be playing it
for years to come but it's still only
second best the winner is super time
force we know that you're surprised and
we certainly didn't expect capybara
time-bending shooting to land in the top
spot either but the more we talked about
how crazy inventive and satisfying the
game is the more clearer it became that
it deserved to be number one at first
super time force gets by on it's
ridiculous story and novel time mechanic
being able to rewind your action so you
can fight alongside your past self is so
damn intriguing that we were immediately
sucked in super time falls is so much
more than one great idea though although
you can often use brute force to succeed
when you push yourself to be more
proficient a beautiful elegance emerges
working in tandem with your previous
characters creates a smart dynamic in
which you must use completely different
play styles
simultaneously maybe powering through
with Jeff leopard while being a
defensive rock as she'll deal uh Kison
it was not until we vanquished the
shocking and Fawcett super time force
really opened up though once you unlock
super hardcore mode you see the full
potential of this brilliant game no
longer can you use brute force to
survive instead every life matters so
you must play with patience and
precision even while the clock is
ticking to your doom it's this murder
pushes the initial concept as far as we
thought possible and that turned us
completely to super time force aside
like a flash of hope may burst upon us
with more amazing games that we could
ever have imagined we haven't even
mentioned the likes of Kentucky route
zero audible among us yet which further
their already mesmerized with stories
who would have thought the month before
e3 would make us care so much about the
present rather than what the future
holds but that's what may had in store
for us and super time force was the best
of the bunch
you